this morning NASA's new at satellite
designed to measure ice sheets over the
North and South Poles is in its
permanent orbit the advanced icesat-2
launched last month from California it
replaces the satellite that failed in
2009
since then nASA has relied on operation
IceBridge which sends planes to
Antarctica from South America to study
how fast ice sheets are melting Mark
Phillips went aboard for the latest
installment in our climate Diaries
series he spoke to the scientists about
working at a time when climate science
seems to have fallen out of political
favor the crew on these NASA flights
over Antarctica here the automatic
cockpit alarm go off a lot it's what
happens when you convert a
fifty-year-old plane into an airborne
lab and fly it really low over the
Antarctic ice cap but 1,500 feet is
where you have to be for the lasers and
radars and cameras to gather the best
data they can on what the ice is doing
and what it's doing is melting at an
ever quicker rate unless ice mission
scientist John Sonntag says means more
rise to the world's sea levels it's not
easy being a government climate
scientist these days not when the chief
executive of the government rejects
sword' ignores your work as president
Trump confirmed again to Lesley Stahl
this week on 60 minutes
what about scientists who say it's worse
than ever you have to show me the
scientists because they have a very big
political agenda yet up here they insist
they have no agenda
they let the data do the talking and the
data is not in denial policy people
we're just engineers the scientists I
don't know anything about politics but I
do know how to measure changing eyes
which isn't to say they aren't
passionate about what they do
you look out the window I just see like
artwork almost it's just so beautiful
Lynette Boisvert is a scientist who
isn't here just to look out of the
office window science prevail yeah my
hope is at the science prevail I think
it will because of the long in the long
path of human history always has science
and hope 1500 feet above the ice for CBS
this morning I'm Mark Phillips over
Antarctica all right mark